Hey, this is really interesting.
Our friend Maggie Hassan has a new show on
Peacock Peacock.
As I understand, that is a new streaming network
offshoot of NBC or MSNBC.
It's it's it's NBC related.
One of the NBC and Metty interviewed former
Trump national security adviser John Bolton.
Now, John Bolton was also one of the architects
of the Iraq war.
I don't think John Bolton knew what to expect
when he was interviewed by METI.
I don't think he realized he was going to
be confronted brutally by Maggie Hassan.
It's really a pleasure to watch.
So let's dig into a clip where many Hassane
asking John Bolton whether he regrets all
the people that died as a result of the Iraq
war, which Bolton pushed and helped orchestrate.
Let's get into the first clip.
So let's talk about the complex issues.
You said you wanted to discuss.
You say in your book that unlike Mike Pompeo,
who had to recant his support for the Iraq
war during Senate confirmation hearings, you
didn't have to because you were not confirmed
by the Senate as national security adviser.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
You don't have any regrets.
You never have apologized for the Iraq war.
Unlike a lot of other former supporters of
it, like Joe Biden.
So what I'm wondering is all those thousands
of people who died in Iraq.
All of those innocent Iraqi civilians, men,
women, children killed by U.S. airstrikes,
some of them in massacres at Haditha, Mahmoudiya,
Balad.
None of those weigh on your conscience.
None of those deaths ever keep you up at night.
You don't know what you're talking about.
The Iraq war, which was the period that lasted
about four weeks and resulted in the overthrow
of Saddam Hussein, was a brilliant military
victory by the United States and other coalition
forces.
And that the removal of Saddam Hussein from
power was the right idea at the time.
And it's true today where the United States
made a mistake.
And I've said this repeatedly over the years,
as in the period following the overthrow of
Saddam Hussein.
I do not think we should have set up a Coalition
Provisional Authority.
I think we should have kept their troops in
Iraq for a lot of reasons.
I think we should have turned responsibility
for the government over to Iraqis as soon
as possible.
You do not increase people's political maturity
by making decisions for you, increase their
political maturity by making them make decisions
for themselves.
So people talk about the Iraq war as though
it started in 2003 and lasted until 2011,
when Obama withdrew everybody.
As if every single decision in that eight
year period followed inevitably unalterably
from the single decision to invade in 2003.
And that's simply not right.
This is super interesting because it's a really
cynical way of looking at the war.
When John Bolton says, listen, the war was
four weeks, it was a single military operation
and we won it.
Everything else that happened is not the war.
It's other stuff and decisions made by other
people.
This is like saying, listen, Vietnam itself
didn't really cause that much chaos, you know,
endless numbers of veterans needing treatment
for life and political problems.
It was really the management in the five years
that followed the Vietnam War that were the
problem.
We can't really blame the Vietnam War for
all of those problems.
Well, would any of that have been the issue,
unissued if we didn't go into Vietnam in the
first place?
So when John Bolton says it was a four week
thing, that went fine.
A military operation.
Everything else.
Wasn't the Iraq war, including all the troops
and civilians that died after the four weeks?
It's laughable.
Imagine a surgeon saying, listen, the brain
surgery itself went fine.
I mean, okay, as a result, the patient had
three years of complications and bad outcomes.
But that other doctors were dealing with that.
The surgery itself was fine.
Any reasonable person would say these are
the complications that are part of the package.
When you decide to do the surgery, you own
the complications as well.
You hopefully understood that the risks were
understood and necessary given the reason
you did the surgery.
But you don't just walk away and say that's
somebody else's problem.
Let's watch a little more.
And Maggie Hassan actually makes this point
to John Bolton.
You say it's simply not right.
But the reality is hundreds of thousands of
Iraqis die.
There was torture.
Millions of refugees.
And that did flow from the decision by George
W. Bush, Dick Cheney and others in the administration
like yourself to invade Iraq.
Hundreds of thousands of people died.
And just to go back to my question, which
you didn't answer.
Do those deaths never went to those deaths,
never weigh on your conscience?
Was my question, which you didn't answer?
No, I did answer.
Now, I answered again, since you didn't seem
to listen to it.
The fact was, after the overthrow of Saddam
Hussein, a number of decisions could have
been made in different ways.
I don't believe in U.S. participation in nation
building.
I think nations have to build themselves.
Now, this is just outrageous.
Bolton doesn't believe in U.S. nation building
during the Iraq war, which Bolton, by the
way, says was four weeks long during the Iraq
war.
All these neocons were talking about spreading
democracy to Iraq, and he now says he doesn't
believe in nation building and he wasn't the
guy involved in those decisions.
He knew what the Bush administration planned
to do.
And for him to now say, well, they didn't
involve me in those decisions.
Gimme a break.
He believes in four weeks of military and
saying we're done.
And now it's up to them.
And he has nothing to do with it.
And it continues in this bizarre way.
And had the United States follow through with
that approach rather than engaging an extensive
nation building.
The outcome, I think, could well have been
very different.
But delay isn't the problem.
What happened in Iraq on the single decision
to overthrow Saddam Hussein is historically
completely wrong.
But no one is doing that, pointing to the
war and the invasion and the occupation.
You're trying to disconnect the occupation.
With respect, John Bolton, you weren't you
weren't a pundit on Fox News that you were
in government.
I don't remember you quitting in objection
to the occupation.
And the fact is that occupation.
Occupation.
Let me just finish my question and come back
in.
That occupation produced thousands of dead
torture refugees.
Richard Clarke, who was White House counterterrorism
czar at the time, shortly after 9/11, called
it war crimes.
Kofi Annan called the war illegal.
I just wonder, do you ever worry that, you
know, people have tried to do a citizen's
arrest on you in the past?
Do you ever worry you may have to face a court
to answer for that war and that occupation
for the war crimes that happened back then?
Of course not.
Because what you're saying is completely ludicrous.
And those who made those kinds of criticisms
are not reflecting what actually happened.
And I made clear in my first book, surrender
is not an option.
I was largely excluded from actual decision
making on Iraq by Colin Powell because he
felt I had a different point of view than
he did.
So my my observations here are from somebody
who had a pretty good idea what was going
on inside.
I didn't agree with it, but didn't have much
influence over policy.
I'm not trying to duck the issue.
But but you're making an grievous factual
error when you attribute everything that came
after the overthrow of Saddam to the U.S.
decision to do that.
That's called the post hoc ergo propter hoc
fallacy.
Look it up.
OK.
While I look it up.
Let me just ask you that question one more
time.
You keep saying I'm not listening to you,
but I lost twice.
I lost one third.
And I want to talk about Iran and the nuclear
deal.
I know you've strong views that very quickly
on Iraq.
You have no regrets about the thousands of
Iraqis who died in Iraq after the invasion.
They never bother you, never keep you up at
night, never weigh on your conscience.
I didn't say that at all.
And what I'm saying is that the the actual
casualties in the overthrow of Saddam Hussein.
I understand that you're still not answering
the question.
So I think you get the picture there of how
that all went.
Not not well.
Super interesting.
And I've been watching clips of the Meti Hassan
show.
He he's very good at this.
And we are going to continue following and
seeing what other interviews he lands.
But this is very, very interesting.
And I encourage you to watch the full interview,
because seeing John Bolton.
Listen, there's.
No denying John Bolton is an intelligent guy
and that John Bolton is a very articulate
advocate for his completely harebrained neoconservative
foreign policy.
You can't watch and say this guy's an idiot,
particularly when you can compare him to the
people in power right now, including Donald
Trump.
But he was not prepared to actually defend
the morality of what he helped to orchestrate,
because there is you're trying to defend the
indefensible, quite frankly.
And that was very much exposed during
that interview.